aux
jauges tu laisses derrière toi un fils
unique nous pouvons mourir comme ça tout
seul en plus son courant 85 à niort il
devait être dans un état pas bourg avec
les mouches tous qu'il devait me dit tu
étais plus est en famille si cantat
était bien la totalité régaler avec
ses bons loire
bonjour monsieur
j'aimerais me recueillir sur la tombe
c'est mon père mois son fils comprend
toi toi toi pas repartir
cissé qui lui georges souhaitais vous
reconnaitre je souhaite que tu vives 30
jours dans la maison de ta famille tu
pourras alors hérité de tout le
rez-de-chaussée de la maison où tu
pourras tu installé à table
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose qui pue si c'est pas
le fromage 30 jours tous mes trente
jours saints
ne savent pas bien c'est vous là
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui se passe à confronter les
tous là il ya un problème la paix c'est
ma soeur de la marque qui
arrivait dans les villages il ya près d
promettent un grand partira pas vivant
c'est sûr a ajouté pacquiao du
valais se partir toi
c'est toi pour ton physique gaston
maulin l'air sale fils de [ __ ]
la magie sans faute puisque lorsque tu
vois je ressemble comme deux gouttes
d'eau à ton père c'est son sang qui
coule dans mes veines mais moi au moins
chez qui suit
parce que c'est le passé là durant un
singulier coop alsace en galère
ben je vais l'aider c'est normal cc
c'est mon frère ça valait bien de toi
est ce qu'on met sa joie que daf là va
falloir qu'ils portent ses couilles de
transit
[Musique]